hey guys it's me jasmine and as you know
i do love
boba but i'm also super passionate about
dumplings dumplings are just
magical they're like little baskets of
heaven
and love they remind me of family
gathering with your friends
and something i think that is so special
about them is that each family has a
different way of making them
they all partake in the culture and
share their love for dumplings so today
i'm going to show you how to make
two-minute
20-minute and two-day dumplings so
whether you have a couple of minutes
or a couple of days you can experience
the magic of this dish
let's get started so this first recipe
is the two-minute dumpling this is great
in a pinch
not the most traditional way to make it
but if you want something quick
this will do great i have my ingredients
for the filling mushrooms
napa cabbage chives cilantro
some sesame oil soy sauce hoisin
corn starch and just a pinch of salt and
now we're just going to
rinse this you can do all this by hand
but a processor saves a lot of time now
i'm taking a heaping teaspoon of filling
i'm adding it to my dumpling wrapper
then i'll dip my finger in some water
and run it along the edges of the
dumpling wrapper then
you'll take the bottom corner match it
with the top corner
make sure to squeeze out all the air
that you can and then make sure to seal
the sides
and then there it is our first dumpling
my last one just gonna add it to my bowl
gonna just add some water until they're
all covered
and just to keep them from sticking i'm
adding some sesame oil
i'm so excited to eat these i do feel
like my ancestors will come down and
slap me in the face for making this in a
non-traditional way
but i'm sharing the love of dumplings
with everyone
i'm adding some plastic wrap on top and
we're just gonna put this in the
microwave for two minutes stirring
halfway through
our dumplings are ready i'm just gonna
take them out of the bowl with a slotted
spoon here
i also have my sauce i'm using soy sauce
black vinegar
and some chili oil i love my dumplings
super saucy so i'm going to take my
sauce
pour it all over my dumplings and
top it with some cilantro our two minute
dumplings are done they look amazing but
you know what let's give them a try
cheers that filling is so good super
flavorful that sauce really brings it
all together
make sure you don't overcook the wrapper
or also get really gummy
for two minutes this is good but if you
have a little bit more time and want
something great stick around for our
next recipe
all right 20-minute crispy pork
dumplings i
love these so let's start by making our
filling i'm going to start with some
cabbage
some pork ginger scallions
soy sauce dark soy sauce sesame oil
shaoxing wine this is very important to
put in your filling it helps cut through
that like porkiness
of the meat and if you don't have this
you might find it to be a little
porky some cornstarch half an egg
the cornstarch will just help bind it
along with our egg and
a pinch of salt now i'm just gonna mix
all this together
our filling is done let's get to
assembling so i have my wrapper here
just scooping some filling placing it in
the center
i'm going to take some water you saw me
do this in the last one
now i'm going to take the center on the
bottom match it with the top and i'm
going to
fold this outer edge in and then as we
come to a close i'm going to fold this
outer
fold well and just pinching on the sides
now i like to take this part
and curl it towards me just a little bit
and now we're gonna repeat on the other
side
i think if you're making dumplings for
the first time
this might feel a little bit stressful
but after a few you'll get it down and
you'll have yourself a cute little
dumpling and then i'm putting it on a
lightly floured
sheet tray here if your workstation is
super warm the wrappers can get a little
soggy and start to stick so i like to
have it lightly floured so i'm going to
keep going until i've made 24 dumplings
my dumpling babies are done i'm ready to
pan fry these for that crispy bottom let
me go get my pan
it's time to cook the pot stickers i
have some oil on my pan here so i'm just
going to place dumplings all around the
pan
i like to do a circular motion you want
to avoid overcrowding the pan because
you don't want them to stick together
and also you want to avoid cooking them
unevenly
right when i put them down i like to
move them just a little bit just to make
sure the bottoms aren't sticking so once
the bottoms of your dumplings are golden
brown
like this we can go ahead and add some
water
to finish cooking it with some steam so
this is another reason why you don't
want your pan to be super hot because
once you add your water into the oil it
can splatter
and it hurts speaking from experience so
once these are done
i'm going to finish the second batch and
we will be very close to eating
these are about done i'm ready to eat
look how beautifully crispy and golden
brown it is
our dumplings are ready let's go ahead
and plate them it smells
so freaking good i'm just fanning them
out
leaving some of the crispy sides up and
that'll help keep them
nice and crispy i'm just gonna sprinkle
some scallions on top
and some toasted sesame seeds i'm gonna
dip my dumpling in my sauce to make the
sauce i whisk together chili oil
low-sodium soy sauce black vinegar
sesame oil
brown sugar and ginger so i like to
completely dunk
my dumpling in the sauce and after the
first bite of my pot sticker
i dunk it again and let the sauce
infiltrate the entire
dumpling wrapper that crispy bottom
has a great crunch the bounciness of the
wrapper
and the filling has like the perfect
amount of flavor these are so good
i am going to finish all of them but
again stick around for the next one
we're making shalom ball
two days if you got two days can we cut
for like five minutes so i can just
really finish this old
plate onto our final recipe of the day
this one takes two days but is seriously
a showstopper
these are soup dumplings we call them
shalom bao translated it's
little basket bun we're gonna start by
making the pork broth which actually
takes the whole first day but it's worth
it to get started i already have some
boiled pork neck and pork skin
for this i've added my pork neck and my
pork skin
covered it with water about two inches
above
i brought it to a boil strained it and
rinsed it with cold water
this will help our broth gelatinize
so we can easily incorporate it into our
soup dumpling i'm gonna add
water ginger scallion rice wine
and peppercorn all of these mixed
together will help enrich the flavor
the rice wine and ginger will help cut
through that porkiness
so a lot of recipes for soup dumplings
actually use gelatin as a shortcut but
we're using
pork neck and pork skin because it has
natural gelatin in it you can totally
use gelatin if you want but today we're
going to go the more traditional route
now we're just going to let it come to a
boil we'll let it simmer for a couple
hours
occasionally skimming the top alright
now i'm just going to strain them so
that we get a very smooth and clean
broth
we're going to let this cool and set it
in the fridge overnight all right now
it's time to make our pork filling i'm
adding some ground pork
ginger scallions soy sauce
sesame oil rice wine sugar and lastly
some water
now i'm just gonna mix this together it
already smells so good
uh yes it's day two i'm wearing the same
shirt because we had
pork broth prepared katie didn't want to
stay overnight i don't want you back
tomorrow
all right this filling is done we're
going a little extra if you want to know
how to make dough from scratch that's
what we're doing next
first i'm adding some flour salt and
some warm water
i personally like to mix with chopsticks
what i grew up with so once i
get a dough formed i'm going to transfer
it to my work surface
you want the dough to be really smooth
if you feel like your dough is a little
sticky you can add just a little bit of
flour
and knead it for about 20 minutes
all right the dough is done now i'm just
gonna take some plastic wrap we're gonna
let it rest for
30 minutes so our dough has rested so we
are going to begin rolling out our
wrappers
so i've divided the dough into two and i
don't want it to dry out so i'm just
going to cover it with a damp towel and
i'm rolling this to
about an inch thick log and i'm going to
split this into 12 equal pieces i rotate
it as i go
because if you keep doing it the same
way it just kind of flattens and it's
harder to gauge
that evenness while these are not being
rolled out i'm just gonna take these and
put it under my damp towel
so i'm gonna roll this into a ball i'm
gonna use my palm and press it down
and at this point you don't want your
dough to be super sticky flour
generously as needed once you have it in
a flat circle we're just gonna roll it
out until it's about three
inches in diameter and now you want to
leave
the center of your wrapper slightly
thicker than your edges so i'm holding
my wrapper
with my non-dominant hand and on the
side
furthest away from me and with my
dominant hand i'm using my roller
and just kind of starting this motion
pick this up and i just kind of rotate
it to get the edges so i start the
pressure
closer to the middle of the wrapper so
that way the the thicker side of the
dough
can press outwards and there you have it
a little wrapper now i'm going to repeat
this process until i've used up all my
dough time to assemble i have all my
wrappers here
covered with a damp towel now we can
begin filling and folding
by the way look that was our broth move
quickly because this
really will turn to soup i have my
wrapper i'm going to add a little bit of
filling
a little bit of crab paste now i'm going
to add some of the soup
and i'm going to begin pleating and i'm
not using water for this so i'm kind of
just pushing
one side until it folds and pinching it
together
and trying to pleat the same amount of
dough fold after fold
so you really want to make sure it's
sealed at the top because the soup will
spill out
let's repeat this a few more times until
we have no more wrappers all right it's
time to cook
i'm going to put my bamboo steamer on
top of my pot and then i'm gonna lay
some napa cabbage this will keep it from
sticking onto
the bamboo steamer now i'm putting my
soup dumplings on the cabbage
now we're gonna do the second row you to
make sure you give them enough space
because they'll just expand a little bit
they're so cute bye love you
now we're gonna let these steam for
eight minutes until they're done the
soup dumplings are done and i am ready
to feast
okay so here we have a set of very
traditional dipping sauces we have black
vinegar
homemade chili oil and thinly sliced
ginger so this is how i usually eat it
i'll take a small bite and then when
it's piping hot
i like to suck out the soup and then i
dip it in my black vinegar
chili oil the soup
melts into your mouth the pork and the
crab together are super super tender and
that skin
and that soup dumpling wrapper is nice
and thin everything just works together
so perfectly these are so delicious i
know they took two days to make but it's
super worth it i'm happy that i made all
these dumplings and i'm happy i get to
eat all of them
today was so much fun i've gotten to
show you how to make two minute veggie
dumplings
20-minute crispy pork dumplings and
two-day
shalom balls or soup dumplings these
were so delicious
i know every family has their own way of
making dumplings if you have a special
recipe that you'd like to share
make sure to leave it in the comments
below and remember there's always time
for dumplings bye oh yes
[Music]
you